the bombs over mario pole drop both day
and night
this is as close as we can get to the
hell unfolding there
but on the ground brave civilians are
risking their lives to send pictures to
the outside world
780 evacuees from mario pole arrived in
the western city of levive earlier
their stories now one of the few ways
for the world to learn the horrors
unfolding there
alina managed to escape five days ago
there are lots of people in mariopol now
you cannot even imagine how many
children are there
there was a six day old and three months
old children in the shelters there are
so many of them
in the neighboring house two little
girls became orphans and just watched
their father dying
and the neighbors took them in
they are still in my opinion because
they cannot leave
alina only learned her apartment had
been bombed after seeing this image
online the fourth floor from the top was
her home until a few days ago
levi's train stations are packed with
families who fled fighting each has a
story of sadness and suffering
alana and her little boy are here from
kiev
clutching his deflated football they're
trying to reach relatives near dinipro
they were bombings it was very loud we
saw and heard shootings on the streets a
busby's army cadets was shot at
my son couldn't bear it anymore
emotionally he couldn't sleep at night
that's why we left
dennis is a reminder dangers have
reached the west of ukraine too
injured in the attack at the military
base just 15 miles from the polish
border
bombed by russia a little over a week
ago
he temporarily lost his sight after the
attack
a lot of people died but we are still
alive as for my injuries i have a
fracture of the facial bone shattered
elbow and joe and some bruises
so many here are getting on trains with
little idea of a plan beyond survival
10 million people in ukraine have been
made homeless since the start of this
war
leaving with the precious few things
that they can carry
but also bearing the stories of the
horrors unfolding in the cities that
they're fleeing
the people escaping mario paul it's one
of the few ways now that the world can
learn what's happening in their city
new satellite images show the theater
and mario poles surrounded by burning
buildings rescue workers still unable to
reach a thousand civilians thought to be
trapped under its rubble
the most frightening thing is that the
world will forget about mario
that they will talk about us for a day
two days and then mariupol citizens will
be just dying there in the basements
she's escaped with a message from mario
paul don't forget about us
sally lockwood sky news la viv in
western ukraine